help me understand what exactly is
astrology so astrology is the study of
the quality of light as it appears in
the sky the moment you take your first
breath or the moment something is
conceived we look to the sky to see what
is happening what market is made and we
make meaning out of that mark it's kind
of like having a map of your life and so
if you give me a map of where you are I
know that you're right now in a studio
in Midtown in Manhattan and so you can
want to be in Paris
well you're not and you could get there
but right now you're here and so then I
can tell you about the quality and the
temperament of Manhattan because it's a
very specific type of place so your
astrology chart is a map of where your
you are in this lifetime but it's not a
map of where you're going you have your
own free will within that but there are
things that are structured into it that
you as an astrologer I would say what
you're probably going to have to deal
with this and but how you deal with it
is your choice and therefore the outcome
can change significantly and you have
that agency as a human being what kind
of meaning can you divine from studying
the planets and studying these charts
what kind of you mentioned meaning yeah
I don't know why astrology works oh I
don't know how astrology works I just
know that it does work and that's why I
work with it so I've sat with thousands
of strangers and talked to them about
their chart and it resonates very
specifically with them this seems to be
a way to be able to look at somebody's
life and give it context it's part of
the challenge or has part of the
challenge been that for so many years up
until recently the way that people have
been exposed to astrology is a three or
four sentence blurb and a supermarket
tabloid and somebody reading that would
say well of all the millions of people
that are Sagittarius is this gonna
happen to all of us can't be real yeah
I'm moving on yeah has that been part of
the challenge for you and for perhaps
people who are skeptical about so
Sun sign horoscopes the things you read
in papers are online now are not there
like one crumb of astrology's cake like
it's a such a very specific and very
generalized way of delivering astrology
to the masses and so that correlated
with the printing press and so they
started writing Sun signs as horoscopes
which were really they're really new
like astrology thousands of years old
and sunshine horoscopes are like 100
hundred fifty years old
like that's not astrology and it hasn't
been for like thousands of years but
it's the way that we've modernized it
and been able to deliver it through
these modes of communication let's go
back a bit and step back and and talk
about you for a moment what was your
path to astrology hmm so I had a reading
when I was twelve years old
the first reading and I had it with my
stepmother and her children and my dad
and we all had a reading from this
astrologer and it was just something
that I felt immediately resonant with
and I felt like it was something that I
knew what she was talking about but I
had never been talked to about it and so
it captivated my attention and it was a
tool that could help me to differentiate
myself it was like a therapy session it
helped me to distinguish oh that's why I
take everything really personally and
that's why my step sister can do that
and that's on my dad does that all the
time and it it just helped me to feel
less alone and it normalized the way I
dealt with life and looking back now was
it it inevitable that you would have had
that reading when you were 12 12 is a
very specific age in astrology
it's a Jupiter cycle so Jupiter of
course
the God of the king of the gods the
biggest planet at least in our solar and
about knowledge and wisdom and healing
there are some who are wondering because
of the moment astrology is having right
now is it in many ways or for many
people replacing religion religion and
astrological phenomena or astronomical
phenomena are connected and so maybe the
yearning for something that will give us
a structural meaning to our life or give
us
context her life and the finding of
something in astrology is actually what
the essence of parts of our religions
hold the search that people have or
meaning for answers to questions that
they may not even know that they're
asking does that mean then that you
remove free will from the equation
something you mentioned earlier because
if you can read a chart and you can tell
me this is the path my life is going to
take and where is the agency I won't say
this is the path your life is gonna take
but I but I will say these are some
things that look really important for
you
and I would be remiss if I didn't tell
you like please yes go explore this
thing and if you have a desire to go do
this other thing that also is very
resonant with your chart are there
moments when you say you know what don't
take that job you know what that you
know that blonde that just walked in the
room don't talk to her she would know
you may be attracted to her because I
think human beings they want to be they
want to feel as if the decisions they're
making are good decisions they want to
know in their minds that this is the
right thing to do and in some instances
whether it's religion or philosophy or
political ideology astrology they get
some kind of positive reinforcement from
that but these decisions for people
that's what I'm getting at I don't think
you should give your power and your
agency to anyone no professional anyone
I think you should take people's advice
with your own judgment I don't want to
tell you what to do I don't know what
you should do I think you do though and
I'd like to create a space where you
remember that you have a connection to
your own wisdom and your own ability to
feel and understand and critically think
about what the right thing for you to do
is